ciao a tutti bentornati su all'inter
stories oggi nubi in un mixing cadrò
mischiare tutti i miei sardi tiger sia
quelli vecchi che quelli nuovi ne ho
preso alcuni nomi sono curiosa di a
premi con voi in questo c'è un uniforme
dentro figo e poi mettono anche curioso
di mischiare questo grande questo nella
bacinella ve lo riportano un bacino
della secchiello ve lo ricordate
se volete altri slam mixing lasciato un
bel ai grandissimi arrais andrò a fare
altri tre meeting magari con il file non
lo so vediamo quindi lasciate un bel
like si esporti vestitevi como di
patatine pop corner e infiamma subito
allora iniziamo da questo che se vi
ricordate questi passano gli slam che si
possono fare da soli pratica
dentro c'era una polverina bisogna mi
schiero con l'acqua e poi si trasforma
in slime se non avete visto il video mi
faccio vedere come si fa
alla fine di perseguire il momento il
quadratino per andare a vederlo e in
pratica non ero rimasta molto contenta
perché il times era rimasto molto pc
cose molto liquido forse avevo subito
qualcosa io però mi avete detto che mi
avete detto che dopo un po di tempo
sarebbe stato più a fare cose
e infatti guardate un po è comunque un
po in salvo particolare e diversa da
quella degli altri slime tiger che sono
molto peggiori gelatinosi questa
consistenza è un po diversa e un punto
la finanza ma è anche un molto più
elastico vediamo se fa qualche suono
a moltissimi suoi questo vediamo se per
qualche solo booking no oddio se spinge
teme qualche suono lo fa qualche sono lo
fa ma niente di che diciamo quindi
questo era lo sta in quel fai da te con
la polverina primo tratto ovviamente nei
commenti indovinate come sempre secondo
voi di che colore diventeranno tutti
questi due nomi schietti secondo slime è
lo stesso quello fai da te
questo è un po più duro forse possiamo
messo nella mappa quindi stesso concetto
di slime fai da te con la polverina di
tiger questo è un chilo meno estendibile
mi sembra abbastanza elastico se si
tratta un pochettino e questo fa qualche
solo in più solo un pò strano però
pensate di questo estremo fai da te con
la polverina di stryker doc
niente paul king o che andiamo a unire
anche questi ora prossimo ecco qua vi
ricordate questo questo l'ho preso lo
stesso nel video in cui più fatto vedere
se di slam più preso da tiger questo è a
forma di conchiglia per il contenitore
la cosa bella
non è che dentro c'è la ritrovo e poi mi
piace molto anche il colore che questo
vediamo se si manterrà una volta che le
che stiamo tutti il collo ecco la perla
non ce n'è più di uno
ci sono due perle eccola qua e l'altra e
quale lascia dentro così poi una volta
che mischia most hid lime
vediamo se riusciamo a ritrovarle in
questo stages live comunque che questa
slime mi piace moltissimo e mi piace
moltissimo il colore perché in genere
non fanno gli slavi questo colore una
sorta di verde acqua color tiffany
celestino però la consistenza e diciamo
sempre la stessa del design di tiger
molto gelatinosa che ho già tre colori
più due per climate is live vi è
piaciuto un sacco e devo dire che è che
m'è piaciuto questo del sesso la
consistenza comunque è sempre abbastanza
jersey non come di sali di tiger
però mi piace il fatto che hanno poca un
secchiello el'hanno fatto grave
gli altri colori allora l'unico altro
colore che ho visto di questo è mera
verde sapete che non amo il giallo
terry quindi ovviamente ho preso questo
arancione superfluo
ebbene la scatoletta quindi del
recipiente secchiello perché potete
metterci le mani dentro il sacco anche
suono smr sentite
quindi qualche strano lo sa e poi è
bello grande infatti costanti tra gli
altri è sempre il gelatino superò quindi
la consistenza più o meno è sempre la
stessa non so se modificabile o che su
andiamo a dirlo e abbiamo già un bel pò
di colori qua primo percorso di vederli
il primo che vedo da aprire e questo è
semplicemente una pallina bianca questo
costava un euro
spero che la con se stessi a un po
diversa perché altrimenti non ne vale
molto la pena perché è molto piccolo
però insomma vediamo gli piace la
scatolina affonda come c'era anche gli
altri colori visti andate sera verde o
che assistente miei ad aprirla vediamo
chef dvd e un po oddio sembra tipo book
o meno mai non l'ho preso bird e allora
la
scatolino mi piace un sacco la conservo
però non sarà m
e comunque il solito slime gelatinoso
purtroppo mi aspettavo qualcosa di
diverso anche perché insomma costava un
euro così piccolo ma purtroppo è il
solito sventolati noso il colore devo
dire che mi piace non è male il colore
ma è sempre il solito quindi vi
sconsiglio di comprare questo strike qua
nella sfera a meno che non vi interessa
avere la stretta di plastica però niente
lo slavo e questo non è niente di che
nel frattempo lo slam arancione sta
risucchiando gli altri slime sotto non
vedo l'ora di michele vedere come
diventano tra l'altro poi andrò a
metterli in questa ciotola per vedere se
riusciamo a vedere gli strati gli strati
con i vari colori dopo vediamo comunque
via anche il bianco eccolo qua
andiamo ad aprire questo che interessa
un sacco
in pratica se n'erano vari compari
animali dentro è una sorta di
mini teca per i pesci e dentro c'erano
vari animali che comunque non è sorpreso
perché si possono vedere qua suppongo
che scende fino dentro e con le campane
come sempre ogni volta che faccio i
video della stella marina questo non
sono secolari consiglio una foca borse
non vedo d'acqua poi questi schiavo una
manta cavalluccio marino uno squalo in
grassetto e una tartaruga è un colpetto
io l'ho sempre il delfino andiamo ad
aprirlo vediamo un po come anche perché
sono curiosa perché lo slang sembra un
po trasparente quindi non è super opaco
[Applauso]
la classica ecco qua guardate un po ma
mi piace un sacco l'effetto che sembra
appunto acqua corredate si può vedere il
mio dito dentro
devo dire che questo slime è molto
carino molto originale l'idea questo mi
piace sentite fa anche un po di rumori
andiamo a vedere la consistenza e
cerchiamo di tirare fuori il delfino
allora è un po trasparente non troppo
però vedete la consistenza purtroppo è
sempre la stessa quella gelatinosa degli
slum di tiger e quindi usano
praticamente sempre la sua formula però
quello che cambia è il colore perché è
un po più trasparente allora vediamo un
po come questo del ritiro ancora
ricoperto un po
infine molto carino è di gomma e si
piega comunque è abbastanza morbido
ovvero intendere monca vetere
andremo a mettere anche questa nello
slime ecco qua lo slime anno fa dovete
rendere fino qua
chissà quanto sprofonderà ecco qua
vedete è comunque gelatinoso mi piace
però questo effetto mezzo trasparente
quindi andiamo ad aggiungere anche
questo voi cosa ne pensate di questo che
o tagli date dalla 10 alle slide
acquario andiamo a metterlo sto prendere
fino al prossimo sly che voglio vedere è
questo unicorno dentro dovrebbe essersi
un unicorno
e questi sono dei disegnini di
arcobaleni unicorni e il colore mi
sembra un pò metallizzato un po
glitterato non mi riformato pagato
questo forse 3 euro
non mi ricordo proprio se volete vado a
controllare poi se me lo scrivo nei
commenti
e allora eccolo qua aveva tipo tre
strati di plastica con
un sacco di pezzi qua sopra vabbè siamo
riusciti
allora guardate la scatolina che carina
si sono le sterili vi è poi una delle
stelle
ma mi sembra ok centri l'arcobaleno ok
andiamo ad aprirlo becchiamo attesa non
ci fosse la plastica anche qua invece
non c'è già pronta in media un po come
vedete il colore un po metallizzato a
qualche suono molto lieve farlo ho
sentito qualcosa allora consistenza
sempre la solita consistenza gelatinosa
durante su caso cambia il colore è un po
più trasparente ed è un po metallizzato
e ha anche dei clipper dentro non so se
riesco a vederli non brillano molto
questi click per però più glitter opachi
tipo vediamo un po l'unicorno toglierlo
eccolo qua wow è un ricordo con una
quota enorme ancora tempo
anche questo è commosso e flessibile
infatti si piega molto speriamo
zuccarino devo dire è finito bene
neanche questo finirà nel più strani
mettiamolo in piedi più si rimane interi
quindi questo qua e lo slime la pasta
decisa oppure la solita purtroppo
battesse la tiri troppo questo studenti
tiger si tratta ma sono davvero curioso
di vedere color diventerà coratina di
frattempo questo qua che libero una
piscinetta tipo non lo slide perché è un
ex trasparente quasi vedere le mie fino
qua socio utilissimo tool non prossimo
sly un questi tipi di stimoli mai
provati da tiger fatemi sapere se voi
avete mai trovati queste sono gli
stranieri che stanno in queste scatoline
questo non lo specifico si chiama jean
ping tutti fatti tutti comunque si è
scritto che è sensibile al calore quindi
dovrebbe cambiare colore con il calore
delle mani
in più dovrebbe anche rimbalzare io non
li ho mai provati quindi andiamo a
vedere come solo questo per mio figlio
questa molto di più
mi sembra 4 euro questo aprirlo non
sopporto quando mette uno splash delle
bustine di plastica perché in questo
infatti insieme mentre quella spina
decisamente diversa dagli altri drive
tiger è un po più plaster il nostro però
non troppo mi riguarda i primi skifidol
il colpo e si chiama romano perché si è
un po classe di noi blasfemi noso come
si dice però non troppo un po più
morbido della plastilina è un tipo di
slang diverso sto cercando di vedere
cambiano colore ma non mi sembra
vabbè che qua fa caldissimo e
sicuramente le mie mani sono grandissime
quindi magari il giallo è per il caldo
ma dovrei vedere con no no l'acqua è
fredda dunque ma non ha cambiato colore
quindi sinceramente non so se funziona
come prima di aggiungerlo proviamo a
farlo rimbalzare
vediamo se funziona
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sì sì sì sì solamente rimandato molto
morbido adesso forse perché quasi molto
caldo group per me tu
[Applauso]
e allora possiamo andare a mischiare
tutto quadra date un po quanti colori
più strano ok andiamo mischia e molto
strano perché la consistenza e la stessa
liu che strano questo inglobato bene
devo in fila più bene dentro
che strano un mega slime steiger gigante
guardate la perla si vede qua sopra
io tra l'altro non so se i colori si
mischieranno offre rimarranno separati
però mi sembra che lo stiamo schianto
guardate che strano o cose
l'unicorno sta diventando una specie di
ferla è caduta allora l'arancione domina
sicuramente perché era lo slime più
grande però ci sono delle parti sfumate
guardate pro dobbiamo continuare a
mischiarlo che strano che era una rhein
di tiger così grande o forse un grosso
effetto molto sfumato qua abbiamo
l'unicorno per cerca di scappare bianco
che infatti sta schiarendo l'arancione
bravo la perla cerca di scappare sè
mitissimo
[Applauso]
guardate qua c'è rosa sta diventando una
sorta di rosso allora questo giorno non
si sto facendo molto bene devo dire
ogni tanto si scappa provo a metterlo in
un altro contenitore così potete vedere
anche tutte le sfumature prima continua
rischiarlo altro quindi se fa qualche
poche ma sentite qualche rom lo fa
adesso perché è molto più grande e più
colpi muore di acqua e stabile di darmi
la forza di body che colore è questo
secondo te secondo voi dovete capire che
colore sia forse sempre violetto arancio
scuro mettiamo uno nell'altro
contenitore vediamo se riusciamo a
vedere tutte le sfumature tornano una
campana mia mente
che strano l'imperativo paschi
pesantissimo sembrato un vulcano
allora guardate un po oracolo rosa posto
se però guarda se le sfumature si è di
giallo rosso arancio e blu e non si è
fuso molto bene il colore è rimasto un
po separò
per un bellissimo questo effetto sfumato
guardate qua il blu metallizzato e quasi
un po di rosa eppure ogni volta che giro
cambiano guardate ora passa una
sfumatura di jal enorme con complessa un
sacco così vediamo che strano non per la
scappa
[Musica]
allora ragazzi ha aspettato un po di
tempo e mi sembra che sia giusto me
sembra un violetto scuro scrivete voi
nei commenti secondo voi che colore è
questo slime fatemi sapere i prossimi
video che volete che faccia sul canale
che sono sly mondo slime scrivetemi qui
tutte le vostre idee e anche se avete
qualche idea per quanto riguarda questo
slime se volete che lo trasformi in
qualcosa se volete che ci faccia
qualcosa che ci mischi qualcosa
fatemelo sapere nei commenti e o rapida
su quattro caselline su cui potete
cliccare potete scegliere i prossimi
video da vedere guida dei miei slime of
slime di tiger cliccate pure su quello
che preferite e buona visione chat
esperti